we're living in an attention economy
eyeballs are everything these days and
kudos to you because you're a brilliant
talker you know what you're saying
you're a shock jock like you're a Howard
Stern S type person and some of the
things you say are hyperbolic some of
the things you say are true not
everything is everything for you
um I'm wondering for you what percentage
are you saying just to as a comedian to
be hyperbolic and just to kind of throw
stuff out there and what stuff is
actually factual and true so for
instance I have a phone in my hand this
is a phone and you can Google things
with a phone so
um Voldemort zielinski a couple quick
points he's the same height as your boy
Putin they're both five seven he's not
five four Putin isn't exactly a giant
okay that's one number two I don't give
two shits about the Muslims in the UK
but a quick Google search will show you
that Muslims population will double by
2030. apparently and go from 6.3 percent
to 17 by 2050. this is Google Katie I
don't care thirdly I just Googled
pictures of UK police officers with guns
apparently they got a lot of [ __ ]
guns so my question to you is what
percentage of what you're saying is
hyperbolic getting eyeballs respect we
live in that kind of world Now versus
actually factual and true okay uh let's
go from the start there you showing me
what a phone is and saying this is a
phone no that isn't really the way to
start an argument because that's to
assert that I'm stupid and don't know
what a phone is well you're assuming
we're stupid because we can't Google
things that you say as a factor if you'd
like me to answer what you just sure
you're going to talk over me we could do
either one I could go either way so but
go ahead this is all you
is it yeah go ahead so starting off on
that kind of tone I don't think is
necessary you then go to your phone and
say I can Google this like you've got
the biggest penis on the planet where
you might have the biggest penis on the
planet candy I don't know darling I've
got bigger balls than Caitlyn Jenner I I
actually believe you Katie I actually
believe you but go ahead you're so bad
at listening and then when you stop
talking you say go ahead for just a
moment in time you can Google anything
why don't you Google my name and see
what it says on Wikipedia because you'll
find out that I'm both a monster uh that
I'm bankrupted that I have no uh
background or backbone you'll find out
that I've bedded everybody in the UK
many of those things won't actually be
true so just because you Googled
something that doesn't really make you
Elon Musk darling does it just mean
maybe you can use one or two of your
hands probably at one side of your hand
more than the other it's had more
practice you then talk about zelenski's
height as if that's a fact because you
read it and that's a misinterpretation
of itself isn't it because just because
you read it on Google doesn't make it
true my report does it and then you also
talk about the fact this old statistic
Muslims six percent walk with me my
flower walk with me through London
through Leicester through Birmingham
through Bradford and walk with me
through Minneapolis because you can call
it six percent if you make that
disparate in a population but in the
cities where they cluster together you
will find they have the majority it's
why they have the power it's why we have
a Muslim mayor it's why we have a Muslim
Housing Association it's why we have a
Muslim Police Association and it's why
we have Sharia law in most of our cities
and finally you managed to find a
picture of a police officer with a
weapon well done darling have a gold
star and do some more Googling maybe you
could watch some Cartoon Network while
we adults talk of course there are armed
response officers I said that as part of
my answer but most police officers on
the streets of the UK are not armed is
that okay for you yes my little flower
pot so here's the deal I again I let off
with the wait a minute hold on you've
Spanish wait wait this is totally
breaking weight you need to stop the
business stop value payment because
seriously what he's done he's Googled
police officers and they're holding
weapons which which must make him right
and me wrong I'm literally came here to
talk out my ass but look what he's done
everybody I think that deserves come on
number one thank you Tyler for Googling
it on your end well done
I appreciate again I'd let off with a
compliment that you're a good talker and
you get eyeballs congratulations you're
good at that part of the problem why you
probably pissed people off is you have
major masculine energy so respect to you
so I know you're saying you're married I
don't know about that I know you're
saying that you've got you're a family
woman
but Katie how can we trust Google Katie
I'm using your words against you
beautiful listen to pull your little
winky I will you can Google you probably
have a bigger dick than me I don't know
so it's okay that will become a fact if
you I guess so yeah I don't know if we
can trust Google darling I don't know so
however I know what was your what was
the point I got it I'm giving it your
time you're hyperbolic you get eyeballs
respect I'm also saying not everything
you spew out there is accurate
what was the compliment
you get eyeballs and then you're a good
talker no I think if you're around for
15 or so years in the media it would be
if you were spewing nonsense you'd be
caught out no you'd probably be canceled
everywhere and then where were you
canceled again I'm literally canceled
from countries okay well is that a good
thing are you proud of that I am
actually yes I am well then kudos to you
Katie I'm proud you're doing what you
want to do in life I'm proud of being
deported from Australia for going over
there and calling out the tyranny of
lockdowns out of standing up for those
people who had that done to them the
Australians needed you like they needed
Katie no and that's something I always
make very are you even Australian
so I am not uh American I am not
Australian and I come over here because
I'm a respectful Foreigner and an
outsider that cares about your country
so you're a globalist no I'm not a
globalist well I'm just like if you go
and like I honestly come to United
States and and basically get involved in
politics or you go to Australia get
involved in politics I am not sure what
you're doing I'm not sure what you're
doing I'm asking you genuine questions
and see I can't help but feel you're
kind of angry but I don't know why maybe
I woke up on the wrong side of the bed
today maybe I was I had a British
girlfriend that you remind me of I don't
know however that's actually true story
yeah
I know that's a true story
here's what I genuinely believe here's
what I generally believe I don't believe
you believe me I date a lot harder
chicks than you but here's what I
definitely believe you actually
are a a person that knows what they're
doing you're not an idiot you've been
confronted before you confront a lot of
people you've been you anti-liberalist
anti-multicultural anti-fat
anti-immigrant anti-tattus sorry uh to
inform you Vinnie she doesn't like you
you have tattoos okay so listen Katie
your Crimea River okay there it is Katie
she has a tattoo on her bum Katie I've
taken a lot of heat before I couldn't
take it you can't take heat Katie you
take heat all the time you give heat I
just there's just a lot of noise coming
off you I stop listening I hear a lot of
noise you just sound a little more
proper than me Katie but we're all just
talking
you're making another thing of yourself
sweetie I'm enjoying you carry on
Patrick so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
laughs
[Music]